Hello大家好我是Terry
我知道最近市場震盪呢
很多人開始害怕說有所謂的AI bubble
或是覺得這個recession要來了之類的
但其實到底有沒有這麼嚴重呢
我們可以來看一下
S&P500從10月底的最高點6919
到今天6603
也才大概回調了4.5%
相比之下呢
今年2月份的貿易戰
我們回調了快要19%
然後我們來看這個
重災區的科技股QQQ
從去年
從今年10月底的回調到現在
也就是大概7%
那相比之下呢
今年貿易戰在2月多的時候
回調了QQ回調了大概23%
也是差的蠻遠的
那還是一樣啦
我覺得這次回調呢
相對來講還是一個非常健康的市場自然的反應
你要想市場不可能會一條直線直直往上漲
那在牛市裡面任何一個瘋狂上漲的時段
之後肯定會面臨一個階段性的回調
因為市場它需要一段時間去喘息
而且現在我們已經快到年底了
通常這個時候是很多機構開始獲利了結
然後做一些風險管理
來關掉一些倉位
也是非常非常正常的
那至於現在很多人在講的這個
所謂的 AI Bubble
我覺得我們還非常非常的早
我會下次再做一集影片來好好的去聊一下這件事情
那今天這集影片呢
其實主要是想要跟大家聊一下懸古
關於懸古這件事情
順便我們來復盤一下 Seeking Alpha 的那個
AlphaPix 的懸古表現
我不知道大家還記不記得
就是在一年多前呢
我做了一集影片跟大家分享
我是怎麼用 Seeking Alpha 的 AlphaPix
來做一個懸古的研究
By the way 如果你不知道 AlphaPix是什麼的話
我覺得你可以去回頭看一下我那集影片
裡面介紹非常非常詳細
那我這邊大概說一下好了
就是有一個非常好Track Record的一個量化分析團隊
叫做Seeking Alpha
然後他們把每一支選股的這個研究報告跟結果呢
整理成一篇文章
定期的推送給他們訂閱的用戶
等於是說如果你有訂閱這個AlphaPix的服務的話
你就可以不定期的得到這個量化分析的買入跟賣出的訊號
像比如說我就會收到Email說這支股票目前呢被Picked
被Picked的意思就是他們選擇加入到他們的Portfolio裡面
然後哪一天呢
他們決定要把這支股票或是這個公司給踢掉的話
他們同樣會發一個email給訂閱的用戶說
這支股票在這個Portfolio裡面已經被close掉了
那這個概念其實就有一點像是S&P500的指數
S&P500指數呢
他們每一個季度都會做一次rebalance
去維護這個美國前500項企業的這個清單
那有些不符合的公司呢
每一個季度就會被踢掉
然後就會有其他更符合這個資格的公司會被選進來
那通常被選進來這個S&P500 index之後呢
他們的公司股票會暴漲一波
因为这代表说全世界有投资S&P500 index的人呢
也都变相的去开始投资了这家公司
那AlphaPix跟S&P500 index指数他们不太一样的是
他们没有一个固定的数字说
OK这个Portfolio一定要有多少家公司
然后他们也没有一个固定的时程表
比如说每一个季度都要去rebalance
他们主要就是有一个很强的量化团队呢
在背后去研究去寻找非常值得投资的公司
就是这些公司呢
他们要确保说有非常高的几率
能够超过一般水准投资回报率的公司
他们才会把它纳入这个AlphaPix的portfolio里面
同样的他们也会随时因为觉得说
这家公司的潜力已经到我尽头了
或是觉得风险过高
就会把它们从这个AlphaPix的portfolio里面删掉
所以基本上就是给订阅用户一个买入跟卖出的讯号
外加每一个讯号呢
都会有一篇非常完整的量化分析研究结果的报告
来证明说为什么这家公司呢
值得被纳入AlphaPix的宣估里面
那这个AlphaPix的订阅呢
說實話真的不便宜
原價要499美金一年
499美金的話換算台幣大概就是1300台幣一個月
喔對了因為現在黑五Alpha PIX跟Sicking Alpha的Premium都有大折如果你現在用我影片底下連結訂閱AlphaPix的話就可以打8折原價$499現在只要$399一年這個基本上就是一整年最大的折扣
只有黑五而已
所以想要訂閱的話就不要錯過了
那Premium的話也是一樣有黑五的折扣
好那我們回到今天影片的正題
AlphaPix的選股到底值不值得這個價錢
我們先來看一下他們官方網站自己統計的一個數據
從AlphaPix開始到現在呢
他們開始是在2022年的7月
到今天呢 S&P 500 的投资回报率是 74.59%
而AlphaPix 选股的表现的回报率呢
是 240.32%
也就是说呢 AlphaPix 的表现呢
是远远超过 S&P 500 Index 的
大概是 3 点多倍吧
基本上就是屌打这个大盘的指数
但说实话啦
我是不知道他这个百分比是怎么算的
因为首先 AlphaPix 的运作原理是
他得到一些 Signal 他就会推送给他的用户
那在这一段时间呢
有加入的选股也有离开的
那它的这个240%的ROI呢
我不太清楚它是怎么算的
我也不知道它每一只股票在加入的时候呢
它投资的占比有多少
这些也都没有写得很清楚
而且跟这个S&P500 Index 75%的回报率去比较
这个75%是怎么算的
我也不是很清楚
我不是很确定这是不是一个很公平的比较
它这边是假设在第一天买入S&P500之后
就没有再加仓了吗
还是说只是单纯指数的表现而已
而且其实我们真的去操作的话
大部分人都是以DCA的形式去買入
那如果我們用DCA的算法去算的話
那這個投資回報率又有點不太一樣
所以今天這集影片的目的呢
就是我要實際去算給你看
到底真正的投資回報率有多少
有沒有它上面寫的這麼厲害
那對於這個投資回報率呢
它下面其實有稍微寫到一下
它這邊寫說
AlphaPix uses time-weighted returns
Consistent with global investment performance standards
但是我覺得這可能不會是我們散戶
真正實際去操作而得到的這個回報率
因为假如我们每一次得到这个Signal之后呢
都会去做一个买入的动作
然后当拿到Close的Signal之后呢
我们就会做出这个卖出的动作
那到底这样子的操作
跟我们每天去DCA S&P500指数
是不是真的差这么多呢
这个就是我今天想要在这期影片里面去寻找的一个答案
我想要知道主动的去选股
跟被动的去DCA大盘指数
在Performance上面到底有多大的差别
加上我在上一集影片也有跟大家讲过
我要去实际的操作
根据AlphaPix给我的Signal
去實際的買入
然後等操作一段時間之後呢
再來跟大家分享我的 performance
但是我要誠實的說就是
其實我因為太忙了
就是並沒有所有的signal都完全跟到
最後呢我自己建的那個Alphapix的portfolio
是有點亂掉了
所以把它拿出來展現呢
其實也沒有太大的意義
但是也不用擔心
因為他們已經把所有的
Open跟Close的signal
歷史所有的數據
全部都寫在Alphapix裡面
所以說我可以根據這些歷史的數據
加上現在所有還在Alphapix裡面
沒有被關掉的那些signal
我把這些開關的時間呢
全部丟给AI来帮我去算
然后我们去假设一个条件
就是我们每一次拿到这个Pick的Signal之后呢
我们就会投入1000美金等值的这个股票
那同样的我们同时呢
也投入1000美元等值的这个S&P500 Index
ETF SPY
根据这样子两个稍微比较公平的比较
我们就可以算一下
到底哪个报酬率才是最高的
那因为我们要用这个真实的历史数据去做回撤
所以我就叫ChatGPT帮我写一个Python Script
然後用 Yahoo Finance 的 API 去抓這些歷史數據
等於是說這個 Python Script 就是一個回測的小工具
然後用真實的數據去做一個比較
做一個 Benchmark Test 來算一下到底哪一個手藝才是最高的
那我們現在就直接來跑這個 App
OK 那不到兩秒的時間這個 Benchmark 測試結果已經出來了如果我們是用 A用AlphaPix的话假设我们每次拿到这个Signal我们就操作等价值美元的这个资金
比如说我这边设施1000块钱
然后我们从2022年7月也就是AlphaPix开始
到现在的总收益呢大概会是104%
而相比之下如果我们用同样的资金
在每一次买入AlphaPix选股的同时呢
也买入这个S&P500指数SPY
然后同样在Alphapix建议卖出的时候呢
也卖出同等股数的SPY的话
这样子我们可以得到的这个回报
从SPY那边得到的回报是26.9%
所以Alphapix在这样子的操作下的表现呢
确实是有将近快4倍的回报
那这个跟他们官方提供的数据呢
其实是差不了太多的
我记得我们刚刚看官方的数据
也是差不多比S&P500要强个大概4倍左右
但是呢我后来去想一下
其实我觉得这个比较呢
它的意义没有很大
我们可能会做的事情是
无脑的定期定额去投入
而不是按照AlphaPix
它选股的这个schedule去投入SPY
所以说呢
我这边又修改了一下code
我要它去计算说
假设我们每天都做这个SPY的DCA
然后我们从来不卖出
我觉得这个才比较像是
真的去DCA大盘的一个操作
也就是说呢
跟AlphaPix用一模一样的
这个总投入资金
但是我把这个总资金呢
除以每日的等份
然后每天去等量的DCA
S&P500指数的话
這個回測的結果呢是我們可以拿到38.2%的回報
那這個回報就還不錯
比我們之前那個方法呢還要更高
其中最主要原因就是我們是真的去每天DCA
然後這段時間呢我們也不賣出任何一股
那他的回報肯定會比你DCA然後買了又去賣還要好
但是呢這個回報很明顯還是跑出了這個AlphaPix的Portfolio
那對這個code呢我又稍微做了一點修改
因為我覺得最近幾年呢尤其是過去三年呢
基本上漲幅都是因為AI還有科技股
所以我觉得我们是不是应该拿QQQ来做这个Benchmark Test
会比较有意义一点
因为S&P500里面很多不是科技公司
好那我要加进我的call里面
第一个就是假设我在Alphapix的选股中
每一次投入1000块钱
我就买入1000等值的QQQ
然后当每一次Alphapix给我卖出的这个Signal的话
我就会卖出Alphapix的这个选股
同样的我也会卖出那个等量的QQQ股数
那在这样的条件下呢
我回撤得到的這個數據回報是35.1%
那這個就很明顯比S&P500好很多
但是還是一樣是比不過AlphaPix的選股
那最後一個我加進去這個code裡面做一個比較的就是
假設我們每日定額定投這個QQQ
總共投入的總金額呢是跟AlphaPix一模一樣
然後也是從來不賣出任何一股的QQ
最終呢我們可以得到在過去這三年我們可以得到的是
49.4%的回報
那這個回報確實是已經蠻好的
基本上差不多就是Alphapix的一半左右
那看到這邊應該也蠻清楚的
就是這個Alphapix的Performance確實是蠻強的
我一開始也對他們給的這個數據有點半信半疑
但是實際拿真實的數據去回測一下
確實是比這個大盤還要好
然後也比你去DCA這個QQQ的表現還要好
所以說其實這個500塊錢的訂閱年費呢
我覺得是蠻值得的
至少呢根據過去的數據來看的話
你如果超桌页的話是完全可以跑贏大盤的
那去年看了我那一集影片
然後有訂閱Alphapix的網友呢
也可以在影片底下留言一下
跟大家分享一下你的回報
好那就像我上一支影片裡面講的
我相信這個Alphapix的服務是真的有他們訂閱的價值
不是因為業配我在這邊幫他們吹牛
我是真實的去拿這些數據去跑回測
那確實這個結果真的還蠻不錯的好那就像我上一支影片裡面講的假如你是對學習投資怎麼選股感興趣的話我觉得AlphaPix的这个服务确实是一个蛮不错的学习工具如果你在搭配SickingAlpha Premium的订阅的话
基本上研究个股呢我觉得就已经蛮够用的
他们给订阅用户推送的每一支选股的精选文章
我觉得都还蛮值得你去读的
因为你可以从里面去了解
到底华尔街背后的那些量化分析团队呢
都是从什么方向去思考
那有些网友跟我反映说看不懂英文
看不懂英文
其實現在有非常多的AI工具你可以用
其實最簡單的方式就是
瀏覽器裡面直接點右鍵
然後打開這個翻譯功能就可以了
那AlphaPix第二個我覺得最強的功能
就是可以讓你直接照抄作業
如果你想要有這個超過S&P500
大盤指數的投資回報率的話
或許你可以直接照抄作業就可以得到了
至少我們根據它過去的這些signal去看的話
去回測確實是可以跑贏大盤
但是我要在這邊提醒大家一點的就是
有可能會因為你進場的這個時機
在短時間內導致呢
你可能会跑出大盘
比如说好了
你现在才加入这个AlphaPix
然后你现在看这整个AlphaPix的Portfolio
你每一支股票都进场一点
但是因为你是现在才进场
所以你的进场价位呢
跟AlphaPix那支股票
当时被选出来的进场价位是不一样的
所以在短期呢
可能会有这个performance的差异
所以说你也可以等到
有新的这个选股signal之后再买入
但是这也代表说
因为你没有参与到之前的选股
你整个Portfolio的overall performance
会跟他们官方显示出来的不太一样
我觉得这个就是可能
你需要特別去注意的
那另外一點就是
它每一個選股呢
其實都是有一個rating
你也可以根據這個rating呢
去決定你要投入多少的資金
不用像我剛剛那樣子
很無腦的
每一個股票都投入一定的資金
所以說你可能可以在資金分佈上面呢
也做一些調整
那這樣子的話
你的performance可能也會有點不太一樣
OK 那我們來看一下
AlphaPix上面都有些什麼
目前呢
他們這個portfolio上面
回報最高的是
這家叫Applovin的公司
那這個是真的蠻厲害的
他們是在2023年的11月15號的時候選入的
那個時候呢
Apploving的股票呢
才40塊錢而已
然後到現在呢
這個股價已經漲了快十幾倍
基本上就跟我當時買入Panantia差不多的漲幅
那具體的這個選股邏輯呢
當年的11月15號的時候呢
他們就出了這篇文章
你只要是AlphaPix的會員呢
你在11月15號的時候呢
就會收到email
然後你也可以隨時回去復盤
去看這篇文章
現在回去看這個兩年前的文章呢
確實可以看得出來這個
他們量化團隊是蠻有料的
好啦那還是一樣啦
目前最新的黑五打折
一整年最多的折扣
用我的連結訂閱AlphaPix的話是8折
一年只要399塊美金
也就是說一個月的訂閱費用不到1000塊台幣
我覺得是蠻值得的啦
有興趣的朋友可以去看一下
那Premium的訂閱也是一樣
有8折的優惠
從原本的2991年
現在只要239一年
還有7天的免費試用
那連結我也都會放在影片底下資訊欄
好啦那希望今天這集影片有幫助到你
如果你喜歡這樣子用真實的數據去回測來檢驗的話
記得一定要幫我把影片點個讚
那想要投資美股的話也可以用IB銀透證券
IB也是我目前唯一有在用的券商
除了閒置的現金有3%多的利息之外
基本上交易的手續費也是低到可以忽略
一筆交易可能也就是幾毛錢而已
然後最近IB他們也推出了一張全新的卡片
可以全球零手續費的刷卡出金
之後我也會做一集影片來跟大家分享這張卡片
還有怎麼樣用USDC加密貨幣來入金IB
那基本上我身邊最後用過IB的朋友都跟我講說他們已經回不去其他券商了
因為不論是功能安全性或是保險其他券商實在是差太多了
OK那我也會把我的專屬IB註冊連結放在影片底下資訊欄
還有非常完整的IB註冊出入金教學
中文的版本也已經整理好在我的網站上面
OK那我們下次見囉